The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
HERBERT GROSS: Hi.
Hopefully, by now you have
become well experienced
at computing limits
of double sums.
You've learned to hate
me a little bit more
because the work was
quite complicated,
and hopefully you are convinced
that there must be an easier
way to do this stuff.
And fortunately,
the answer is there
is an easier way sometimes.
And the concept that we're
going to talk about today
is, again, completely
analogous to
what happened in calculus
of a single variable
where we showed that the
concept of definite integral
existed independently of being
able to form derivatives,
but in the case where we knew
a particular function whose
derivative would
be a given thing,
we were able to perform
the infinite sum--
or compute the infinite
sum much more readily
than had we had to rely on the
arithmetic of infinite series.
By the way-- and I'll
mention this later
in a different context, I
hope-- that the converse problem
was also true.
In many cases one
did not know how
to find the required function
with the given derivative,
and in this case knowing how
to find the area by the limit
process was equivalent
to how we were then
able to invent new functions
which had given derivatives.
Essentially, the
difference in point of view
was the difference
between what we
called the first fundamental
theorem of integral calculus,
and the second fundamental
theorem of integral calculus.
As I said, the same
analogy will hold here,
and let's get into this
now without further ado.
I call today's lesson
the fundamental theorem.
And what I'm going to do now
is to pretend that we never
had the lecture of last time.
That we have never heard
of an infinite sum.
I'm going to introduce
what one calls
the anti-derivative
of a function of two
independent variables,
again keeping in mind
the analogy that for more
than two independent variables
a similar treatment holds.
And the exercises
will include problems
that have more than two
independent variables.
The idea is that
when I write down
this particular
double integral, if I
look at the innermost integral,
notice that x appears only
as a parameter.
That the variable
of integration is y
notice then, that x is
being treated as a constant.
What this says is what?
Pick a fixed value of x,
compute this integral,
evaluate this as y
goes from g_1 of x
to g_2 of x-- the
resulting function is
a function of x alone--
and integrate that function
of x from a to b.
And to do that for
you in slow motion,
so you see what happens here,
what I'm essentially saying is,
read this thing inside out.
Imagine some
brackets placed here.
Not imagine them,
let's put them in.
And what we're saying
is, lookit, first of all,
fix a value of x.
Hold x constant.
And for that fixed value of x,
compute f of x,y dy from g_1
of x to g_2 of x.
Compute that, remember
you're going to integrate
that with respect to y.
When you're all
through with this,
because the limits
involve only x,
the integrand that you get--
this bracketed expression will
now be a function of x
alone, call it h of x.
Integrate h of x
dx between a and b,
and the resulting
expression, assuming
that you can carry out
the integration of course,
will be a particular number.
That has nothing to do, as I
say, with double sums so far.
Though I suspect that you're
getting a bit suspicious.
And in the same way that
the definite integral was
a sum and not an
anti-derivative,
the notation of the
definite integral
looked enough like the notation
of the indefinite integral,
so we began to suspect
there was going to be
a connection between them.
That connection is
what's going to be
called the fundamental
theorem in our present case.
But going on, let me just give
you an example showing you how
we compute the anti-derivative.
Let's take, for example
interval from 0 to 2,
integral from 0 to x
squared, x cubed y dy dx.
Again we go from
inside to out, the way
we read this is that we're
integrating with respect to y.
That means we're
holding x constant.
For a fixed value
of x, integrate this
as y goes from 0 to x squared.
So treating x as a constant,
I integrate this with respect
to y.
The integral of y
dy is 1/2 y squared.
I evaluate that as y
goes from 0 to x squared.
That's crucial you see.
It's y that goes
from 0 to x squared.
When I replace y
by the upper limit,
I get 1/2 x cubed times the
quantity x squared, squared.
When I replace y by
the lower limit 0,
the integrand vanishes.
So that what I wind up with
is a function of x alone.
Specifically what
function is it?
It's 1/2 x to the seventh, and I
now integrate that from 0 to 2.
That gives me 1/8 x
to the eighth over 2,
that's x to the eighth over 16.
Evaluated between 0 and 2.
2 to the eighth over 16
is 2 to the eighth over 2
to the fourth, which is 2 to
the fourth, which in turn is 16.
So again, notice, I can carry
out this operation purely
manipulatively.
It is truly the inverse of
taking the partial derivative.
In the same way that taking
the partial derivative involved
holding all the variables
but one constant,
taking a partial integral, so
to speak, an anti-derivative,
involves simply doing what?
Integrating, treating all
the variables but the given
one as a constant.
Which reduces you,
again, to the equivalent
of what the
anti-derivative meant
in the calculus of
a single variable.
Now here's where we come to the
so-called fundamental theorem.
Let me tie what we've
talked about today,
and what we talked
about last time.
Let me see if I can't tie
those together for you
in a completely different way.
Meaning I want you to
see that conceptually,
today's lesson and
last time's lesson
are completely different,
but the punchline is
there's a remarkable
connection between the two.
Let's suppose I take
the region R, which
is a very simple region that's
bounded above by the curve y
equals g_2 of x.
It's bounded below
by the curve y
equals g_1 of x, and that
these two curves happen
to intersect at values
corresponding to x
equals a and x equals b.
And what I would like to find
is the mass of the region R,
if its density is some
given function f of x, y.
Now, in terms of what
we did last time,
this involved a double sum.
What double sum was it?
We partitioned this into
rectangles, et cetera.
We picked a particular number
c sub i, j comma d sub i,
j in the (i, j)-th rectangle.
We computed f of c sub i, j
comma d sub i, j times delta
a sub i, j, added these all up.
The double sum as i went from
1 to n and j went from 1 to n,
and took the limit as the
maximum delta x_i and delta
y_j approach 0, and that
limit, if it existed--
and it would exist if f
was piecewise continuous--
that limit was denoted by what?
Double integral over the
region R f of x, y dA.
And that dA could either be
viewed as being dy*dx if you
wanted, it could be dx*dy,
It could also be, say,
in different coordinate systems,
we're not going to worry about
that part just yet.
We'll worry about that
in future lectures.
Now, on the other hand, let's
stop right here for a moment.
Let's see how one
might have been tempted
to tackle this problem
from a completely
intuitive point of view.
The so-called
engineering approach,
if you would never heard
of the anti-derivative,
anti-derivative for
several variables,
but had taken part
one of our course.
The engineering approach
would be something like this:
you would say, let's pick a
very small infinitesimal region
here, in which we can assume
that the density is constant.
So we'll pick a
little region that's
a very, very small
rectangle of dimension what?
We'll say it's dy by dx.
And the density of this
particular rectangle
can be assumed to be the
constant value f of x, y.
Because that
density is constant,
the mass of this little
piece should be f of x,
y times dy*dx.
and then we say what?
Let's add these all up.
Let's go down to
here we say lookit,
this is a typical element.
And we'll add them all up
for all possible y's and all
possible x's.
Now how would you
do this intuitively?
You'd say well, lookit,
let me hold x constant.
Well, for a constant value
of x-- let's call it x sub 1.
For a constant
value of x, notice
that y can vary any place--
to be in the region R,
for that fixed value of x, y can
be any place from here to here.
In other words, y
varies continuously
from g_1 of x_1 to g_2 of x_1.
Or, because x_1 could have
been x, for that given x,
y varies continuously
from g_1 of x to g_2 of x.
And notice that x
could have been chosen,
if we want to be in the region
R, to be any place from a to b.
And so mechanically,
we might say,
let's just say, here is the
mass of a small element,
and we'll add these all
up so that for a fixed x,
y goes from g_1
of x to g_2 of x.
And x could be
anywhere from a to b.
And it appears that
this is a truism.
This is not a truism.
It's a rather
remarkable result. It
is analogous to what happened in
calculus of a single variable.
Namely, notice that when we had
the definite integral from a
to b, f of x dx, that
was an infinite sum.
It was summation f of
c sub k, delta x sub k,
as k went from 1 to
n taking the limit
as the maximum delta
x sub k approached 0.
It turned out that if we
knew a function capital
F whose derivative was
little f, then this sum
could be evaluated
by computing capital
F of b minus capital F of a.
Again the idea being
that if you knew
a function whose derivative was
f, that gave you an easy way
to evaluate the sum.
On the other hand,
if you didn't know
a function whose
derivative was little f,
evaluating the sum
as a limit gave you
a way of being able to
find the anti-derivative.
A particular case in
point, you may recall,
was trying to handle the problem
e to the minus x squared dx,
as x goes from 0 to 1.
This certainly
existed as an area,
but we did not
know-- in fact, there
is no elementary function.
We invented one, called
the error function,
whose derivative is e
to the minus x squared.
So the idea is-- and
this is the key point--
this is what becomes known
as the fundamental theorem
for several variables.
That there is a connection
between a double infinite sum,
and a double anti-derivative.
That this particular
expression here
does not involve
knowing anything
about partial derivatives.
This particular
expression here does not
involve any knowledge
of knowing partial sums.
This simply says what?
Integrate this thing twice.
Once holding x
constant and letting y
go from g_1 of x to g_2
of x, and integrating
with respect to x.
And the amazing result is
that if f is continuous,
this limit exists,
and in particular,
if we happen to know how
to actually carry out
these repeated or
iterated integrations,
we can compute this
complicated sum simply
by carrying out this
anti-derivative.
And I think the best
way to emphasize that
to you is to repeat the
punchline to the homework
exercises of last assignment.
You may recall that last
time we were dealing
with the square whose vertices
were (0, 0), (1, 0), (1, 1),
and (0, 1).
The density of the square
at the point x comma y
was x squared plus y squared.
And I asked you as
a homework problem
to compute the mass of this
plate R, to compute it exactly.
And we said OK, by
definition of-- remember,
this thing here now,
with the R under here,
indicates a limit
of a double sum.
That this mass was by definition
this particular result.
And notice that
last time we showed,
in terms of double sums,
that this came out to be 2/3.
Let me show you in
terms of our new theory
how we can find this much more
conveniently, with no sweat,
so to speak.
What I'm going to do now is the
following-- The same analogy
I used before.
I look at my region here, which
I'll call A, and I say what?
For a fixed value of x.
For a fixed value
of x, notice that y
varies continuously from 0 to 1.
See, y varies
continuously from 0 to 1.
And then x, in turn,
could have been chosen
to be any place from 0 to 1.
That as we run through all these
strips, added up from 0 to 1,
that covers our region R.
So what we're saying is,
all right, a little element of
our mass will be x squared plus
y squared dy*dx.
We'll add these all up from
0 to 1, holding x constant.
Then add them all up again,
as x goes from 0 to 1.
Again, this is the
iterated integral.
How do we evaluate this?
Well we treat x as a constant,
integrate this with respect
to y.
If we're treating
x as a constant,
this then will come out to be
x squared y, plus 1/3 y cubed,
and we now evaluate that
as y goes from 0 to 1.
Leaving these details
out because they
are essentially the calculus
of a single variable
all over again, this turns
out to be the integral from 0
to 1 x squared
plus 1/3 dx, which
in turn is 1/3 x cubed
plus 1/3 x, evaluated
as x goes from 0 to 1.
The upper limit gives me a third
plus a third, the lower limit's
0.
The mass here is 2/3, which
checks with the result
that we got last time.
Again, I'm not going
to go through the proof
of the fundamental theorem, I
don't think it's that crucial.
It's available in textbooks
on advanced calculus.
Some of the exercises
may possibly
give you hints as to how
these results come about.
But by and large,
I'm more interested
now in you seeing the overview,
and at this stage of the game
letting you get whatever
specific theoretical details
you desire on your own.
At any rate, let's
continue on with examples.
I think a very nice
counterpart to example one--
and to refresh your memories
without looking back at it,
example one asked us to
compute this anti-derivative.
And what I'd like to
do now is to emphasize
the fundamental theorem by
wording this a different way.
What I want to do now is
to describe the plate R.
If its mass is given by the
double integral over the region
R, rho of x, y, dA and that
turns out to be integral from 0
to 2, 0 to x squared,
x cubed y, dy*dx.
What is the region
R, whose-- what
is this region R, if this
is how its mass is given?
The first thing I
want you to observe
is that this part here is
identified with the density
part of the problem.
And that these
limits of integration
determine the region R.
For example, what this says
is, if you hold x constant,
y varies from 0 to x squared.
Let's see what that means.
If you hold x constant,
y varies from 0-- well y
equals 0 is the
x-axis-- to y equals
x squared-- that's this
particular parabola.
What this says is, for a fixed
value of x, say x equals x_1,
to be in the region
R, you can be
any place from the x-axis
along this strip up to y
equals x_1 squared.
So your strip is like this.
Then we're told that in
turn x could be chosen
to be any place from 0 to 2.
So now what we know
is that this strip
could have been chosen for any
value of x between 0 and 2.
And what that
tells us therefore,
is that the shape
of our region R
is the curve-- the
region that's bounded
above by the curved y equals x
squared, below by the x-axis,
and on the right by
the line x equals 2.
This is our region R.
You see, the region R
is determined by the
limits of integration,
and the density of R
is given by rho of x, y
equals x cubed y at
the point x comma y.
OK?
We'd mentioned before that why
do you have to write dy*dx?
Couldn't you have written dx*dy?
What I thought I'd like to do,
for my next example for you,
is to show you how one
inverts-- or changes--
the order of integration.
For example, given the same
integral, the same region R,
suppose we now want to express
the mass in the form double
integral x cubed y dx*dy?
You see the region R is still
the same as it was before.
But now you see what we want
to do, how would we read this?
This says we're integrating
with respect to x. x is varying.
So this says, for a fixed value
of y, integrate this thing.
See, for a fixed value
of y, integrate this.
Evaluated between the
appropriate limits
of x, in terms of y.
And then integrate
this with respect to y.
Well, what this says is let's
pick a fixed value of y.
Let's say y equals y_1.
For that fixed value of y
notice that the curve y equals
x squared, for x
positive, in inverted form
has the form x equals
the square root of y.
So for a fixed
value of y, notice
that x varies from the square
root of y_1 up to x equals 2.
See, x goes from the
square root of y to 2,
for a fixed value of y.
Now where can y be?
This is our limits here.
To be in the region
R, y could have
been chosen as low as
this, or as high as this.
In other words y varies
continuously from 0 to 4.
And again, because I don't
want to have our lecture
obscured by
computational detail,
I simply urge you
to-- on your own--
compute this double integral,
compute the double integral
that we obtained in
example number three,
and show that the
answers are the same.
What I do want you to observe is
how different the limits look.
Notice that in the other
integral it was from 0 to 2
outside, now it's from 0 to 4.
Notice also on the
inside integral
it was from 0 to x squared.
Now it's from the
square root of y to 2.
There is no mechanical way
of doing this, at least
in the two-dimensional
case, we can
see from the picture
what's happening.
In the multi-dimensional
case, we
have to resort to the
theory of inverse functions,
and this becomes, at best,
a very messy procedure.
Of course, the answer is, if
it's such a messy procedure,
why bother with it?
And so in terms of another
example that I would like
to show you, let me give you
an illustration in which it
may be possible to find
the required answer if we
integrated one order, but not
if we integrate with respect
to the other order.
Let me evaluate the double
integral 0 to 2, x to 2,
e to the y squared, dy*dx.
Again, let me see if I
can at least write down
what this thing
means geometrically
before I even begin.
Notice that I can think
of this as a plate R,
whose density at the point x
comma y is e to the y squared,
and what is the
shape of this plate?
Integrate with
respect to y first.
For a fixed value
of x, y goes from y
equals x-- well that's this
line here-- to y equals 2.
That's this line here.
So for a fixed x, y varies
continuously from here to here.
x can be any place from 0 to 2.
That happens to be the
point 2 comma 2 where
these two lines intersect.
So the region R is this
rectangular region here.
OK, this is our region
R. And what we're saying
is find the mass
of the region R,
if its density at the point x
comma y is e to the y squared.
Now, notice that this density
exists even if I've never
heard of the anti-derivative.
If, however I elect to use
the fundamental theorem,
and I say OK, what I'll
do is I'll compute this.
Notice I'm back
to an old bugaboo.
I don't know how to integrate
e to the y squared dy,
other than by an approximation.
In terms of
elementary functions,
there is no function whose
derivative with respect to y
is e to the y squared.
So what I do is
I elect to change
the order of integration.
Why is that?
Well, because if I change
the order of integration,
sure I'm integrating
e to the y squared,
but now with respect to x, which
means that e to the y squared
is a constant.
This is trivial to integrate.
It's just going to be x
times e to the y squared.
The problem is what?
If I'm going to
change the order here,
I must make sure
that I take care
of the limits of
integration accordingly.
Now what this says is what?
I'm going to
integrate with respect
to x first. x is
going to vary, so I'm
treating y as a constant.
For that constant
value of y, notice
that to be in the region R,
for that constant value of y,
our x varies from what?
x varies from 0 to the line
y equals x, or accordingly x
equals y.
So for that fixed
value of y, x varies
from x equals 0 to x equal y.
And correspondingly,
y can be chosen
to be any fixed number
between 0 and 2,
and that gives me this
particular double integral.
And by the way, from this point
on, the rest is child's play.
Because when I
integrate this, you see,
this integrand is x
e to the y squared.
When x is equal to y, this
becomes y e to the y squared.
When x is 0 the lower
limit drops out.
So what I want to
integrate now is 0 to 2 y
e to the y squared dy.
But this is beautiful for me,
because the factor of y in here
is exactly what I need to
be able to handle this.
In other words, this is
nothing more than 1/2
e to the y squared
evaluated between 0 and 2.
Replacing y by two gives
me 1/2 e to the fourth.
Replacing y by 0-- remember
e to the 0 is one--
gives me minus 1/2, because I'm
subtracting the lower limit.
The answer to evaluating
this integral-- which
was impossible to do in this
form, because of the fact
that there was no elementary
function whose derivative is
e to the y squared--
turns out quite nicely
to be given by e to the
fourth minus 1 over 2.
To summarize today's
lecture, to show you
what the fundamental theorem
really means, all we're saying
is that we often compute
the infinite double sum--
double integral R, f of x, y,
dA by an appropriate iterated
integral.
That's-- what we mean is what?
The anti-derivative.
Integrating-- taking the
anti-derivative successively.
Iterated integral.
See?
And conversely.
In other words, the
gist of this whole thing
is that we now have two
entirely different topics that
are related by a fantastic
unifying thread that
allows us to solve
one of the problems
in terms of the
other, and vice versa.
You see, again, the
analogy being complete
with what happened in the
calculus of a single variable.
That we can evaluate
double sums,
which was the aim of
the previous lecture,
by means of an
iterated integral.
We can evaluate iterated
integrals, sometimes,
by appropriately knowing
how to find the limit
of an appropriate double sum.
And again we shall make use
of this in the exercises.
We will go into this in more
detail from other aspects,
and other points
of view next time.
At any rate, until
next time, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.